du temps des romains ces taxes de
circulation existait déjà
deux mille ans plus tard il est très
empruntée quotidiennement résultats des
bouchons matin et soir pour entrer et
sortir de besançon je suis pas de
besoins sont donc je viens de temps en
temps mais c'est souvent vers stater que
normalement il ya des bouchons j'ai pas
pourquoi peut-être le fait qu'ils
régulent comme ça je sais pas nous on
regarde du jura et c'est vraiment un
tous les matins tous les matins et ses
amis sinon on attend à peu près voire un
quart d'heure tous les matins en fait
circuler donc voilà chaque jour 32 mille
véhicules utilisent cette portion de
route dont près de 3000 camions
trop beaucoup trop selon les riverains
les poids lourds quitte l'autoroute
entre poligny et besançon pour ne pas
payer le péage en projet la mise à deux
fois deux voies de la rn 57 entre beurre
et le contournement est ce la solution
pour moi la réalisation de ces trois
kilomètres 702
voie de contournement devrait doit
améliorer le trafic et notamment supris
supprimer les bouchons de façon à ce que
il ya une meilleure régulation de la
circulation
toute cette portion là elle viendra
taper sur la deux fois deux voies avec
deux nouveaux ronds-points un peu plus
loin et ça continuera d'engorger ça
résoudra rien ici nous le dédoublement
on ne s'est pas une chance pour nous
coût des travaux sur la rn 57 ici sur 3
km 730 millions d'euros dont 42 pour des
modes de transport doux et des
protections pour la faune les élus du
grand besançon voteront ce dossier le 28
juin